today is a day for truth the world needs
to know what happened and to know what
he stands for that kind of power is very
dangerous
let the record show that this committee
holds him responsible
that's how it starts the fever the ray
of turns good men cruel this bat
vigilante is like a one-man rite of
terror you don't get to decide what the
right thing is nobody cares about Clark
Kent taking on the Batman this means
something all some people have all that
gives them hope
people hate what they don't understand
be their hero Clark be there angel dear
monument
be anything they need you think
or be none of it
you don't know this world a thing you
never did do you know the oldest lion
America senator Devils don't come from
Hell beneath us
they come from the sky
20 years in Gotham I made good guys or
left
I'm gonna stayed that way he has the
power to wipe out the entire human race
now I have to destroy it
you're gonna go to war
he is not our enemy
black and blue
God vs Man
day versus night
the red capes are coming the red capes
are coming
hey youtubers is charlie so this is
gonna be my break down to the Batman vs
Superman footage I know the Suicide
Squad trailer leaked to this is like the
Batman vs Superman trailer they showed
in Hall H they also showed that Suicide
Squad footage but they've been pulling
it down so I just I can't post any of
the Suicide Squad stuff so I'll just
talk about it after Batman for Superman
but just a couple things right off the
top Zack Snyder clarified just a couple
big things about the film that there are
some big changes the comic book canon he
said the most egregious thing that he
changed is that now metropolis exists
right next to Gotham City as it is in
like they're separated by a bay and in
the wake of Superman's battle with the
other Kryptonians with Zod it's become
this you know very much prosperous
versus decrepit city like in the wake of
the attack Gotham has fallen on hard
times like we see in the trailer like
the the Wayne financial building coming
down that's part of the thing that
shakes Batman back into action he's
existed in this universe for a while I
know it seems like he's becoming the
Batman for the first time but he's
actually been retired when the movie
picks up so it's like oh [ __ ]
Kryptonians here we need to kill him
like he says in the trailer he can kill
the entire human race we have to get rid
of him so that that shakes him back in
the action so he goes back into training
but as much as the movie has like shots
like visual things that are totally
inspired by Frank Miller's Dark Knight
Returns the movies story like the story
itself has nothing to do with it if
you've seen the panel video that I
posted I mean he says it outright he
just says that the story is something
that we made up in a room by ourselves
it had nothing to do with the comics but
i think is really cool is the way
they're pitting superman and batman
against each other it's not just two
superheroes you know with two different
ideologies going at each other they're
also using their alter egos to do it
Batman is using his wealth as Bruce
Wayne to create Batman tech to take on
Superman and Superman is using his
position as a reporter at The Daily
Planet to take on this Batman vigilante
you know air quotes I like the way that
they put that in the trailer Batman
vigilante you have to remember that
Clark Kent has no idea who the Batman is
but Batman is probably going to figure
out who Clark Kent is really fast
standing in between them is Lex Luthor
with a giant kryptonite rock and zod's
body the way they cut the trailer it
seemed kind of vague like we don't know
if it's the
military the US military that has Dodds
body or LexCorp but I think that it
selects Corp even though in the movie
Lex Corp is a tech company it's not like
Lex Corp in the comics to be fair though
when you're like a billion dollar
company you you have your hands on a lot
of different pies so you could
rationalize him synthesizing kryptonite
you know I knew anyway you want I mean
he has a billion dollars he does
whatever he feels like doing jesse
eisenberg is wearing a wig in this
trailer he is bald but we might not see
him actually go bald to the end of the
movie that might be something that they
save for the most part what looks like
is happening in this movie the big
conflict is going to be super hero
registration you know people so powerful
that they can destroy the human race
they need to be controlled so that's
probably how we find out about all the
other metahumans in the world like we
find about Aquaman all the other big
super heroes that are going to become
part of Justice League Superman causing
all this damage in making everyone [ __ ]
their pants is going to put all these
other supers on the radar so as much as
he has his own like cult-like following
and people that worship Him as as a god
like he even has this security force
that's taking the bit down the Batman
with Superman's symbols on their arms he
is going to be the biggest antagonist of
the film for probably at least the first
half what I'm expecting you know based
on the way that they cut this trailer
like some of the things that we saw is
that Lex Luthor will eventually become a
threat so big that Batman and Superman
will have to join forces presumably
injustice Lee because I think most of
this movie is going to focus on this
Batman Superman story I know they've
been a lot of rumors about doomsday and
other big villains I'm not expecting too
much of that it seems you know mostly
what's going to be happening in this
film is that kryptonite will become a
thing and that people will start picking
sides you know either you're with
Superman or you're with people like Lex
Luthor obviously anybody this Riddick
comic in the last 20 years no knows that
Batman is gonna switch back but I'm
really interested to see Lex Luthor try
to win Batman over like if he tries to
lure Bruce Wayne and obviously he
probably doesn't know that he's Batman
but what about gal gadot though it looks
like she fights Superman a little bit
it's kind of hard to tell the way they
cut the trailer sometimes the way they
cut things can be deceptive but it does
look like they throw down a little bit
because she'd be one of the few people
that could take him on in the context of
this universe she's been around for a
long time so I think she's going to be
an example of a well-adjusted superhero
but let me know that what's your
favorite part from the trailer is that
sad for him seeing Wonder Woman finally
kick some ass moving under Suicide Squad
stuff though so you know biggest thing
from the Suicide Squad footage is
actually seeing Jared Leto's Joker I
mean it looks dark gritty and awesome
you know once we get a nice high quality
version you know which hopefully though
they'll drop pretty soon but for the
most part like during during the panel
video like I posted the Suicide Squad
panel the director David Ayer said
they're being faithful to the comics
he's talking about the classic Suicide
Squad like the 80s Suicide Squad but
they have a giant cast though like
almost every single major Suicide Squad
character that ever was Raina just
because we don't have a lot of context
I'm cautiously optimistic but I do I
think it'll be a lot of fun so what's
going to happen is is the the DC like
super flare Oh legends panel like in all
the DC TV shows is happening tonight I'm
going to be backstage so i'll be live
tweeting no matter what but i don't know
if i'll be able to tape it or not they
said I'm not allowed to record the
screen so we'll see I'll do whatever I
can to get footage like they're doing a
Q&A panel and they're showing off a
bunch of footage so most of my videos
for that stuff like like the Vixen
trailers that just dropped that we'll
all post tomorrow be sure to subscribe
to get everything seriously the Vixen
trailer is actually pretty exciting I'll
talk about the premiere and all that
stuff that's happening in August so I'll
talk about that tomorrow but why you
guys wait for that to drop you can click
here for the Batman V Superman panel in
case you haven't seen it and you can
click on this second link down here for
all my other comic con videos just just
pretend like my hand is like pointing up
and down on the screen here thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you